merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à monsieur laurent wauquiez
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma guérison sur les adresses à
monsieur et il vous plait notre pays est
la principale cible du terrorisme
islamiste et je ne doute pas que cette
question puisse rassembler sur tous les
bancs de l'hémicycle les événements
dramatiques de nice et saint-etienne du
rouvray nous rappelle l'intensité
terrible de la menace mais aussi la
volonté de nos ennemis de frapper des
lieux symboliques nos établissements
scolaires sont plus que j'ai stib halle
rappelons-nous l'attentât de mars 2012
de mohamed merah les familles attendent
de nous que tout soit fait pour protéger
nos enfants nous devons garantir à nos
compatriotes qu'aucun individu fiché s
ne soit recruté dans nos étapes colère
or ce n'est aujourd'hui pas le cas les
maires présidents de départements ou de
régions sont inquiets car lors de
l'embauché de personnel éducatif
ils n'ont aucune information sur des
individus potentiellement dangereux car
il n'y a pas de partage d'informations
votre ministre de l'éducation a elle
même reconnu avoir suspendu une dizaine
d'agents dont l'affiché est ce au sein
du personnel éducatif
est-ce que ce partage d'information est
possible bien sûr car un tel dispositif
existe contre les prédateurs sexuels
les élus peuvent consulter avant toute
embauche le fichier judiciaire
automatisé des auteurs d'infractions
notre demande est donc très précise et
appelle une réponse concrète vous
engagez vous à faire bénéficier aux
maires présidents de départements et de
régions du même système que celui des
prédateurs sexuels pour les fichiers s
c'est le bon sens et écouter cet appel
des maires et des élus terrain de
tendances diverses
nous ne pouvons pas prendre ce risque
n'attendez pas un drame pour agir
personne ne comprendrait que des mesures
de bon sens ne soit pas prise monsieur
le premier ministre c'est l'école de la
république et ses enfants qui doivent
être protégés et ce n'est pas après les
drames qu'il faut agir
mais avant la parole est à monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
sur le député wauquiez vous appelez une
réponse précise et je vais vous la
donner d'abord pour ce qui concerne des
informations dont disposent les
autorités de l'état notamment les
services de renseignement concernant les
fichiers nous sommes encadrés par le
droit et ce que nous devons faire et ce
que pouvons faire compte tenu de ce
qu'est le droit je sais que pour vous le
droit est un ensemble arguties
juridiques que ce sont des chiffons de
papier dont on peu le pas tenir compte
mais nous le droit nous le respectons
parce qu'on ne luttera pas contre le
terrorisme en abandonnant les principes
de l'état de droit que dit le droit est
dit des choses extrêmement précises il
dit que les magistrats qui ont fait des
informations concernant des individus
fichés à ces questions judiciariser
peuvent en vertu de l'article 11-2 du
code pénal communiqué aux élus des
informations dès lors que ces
informations qu'ils communiquent sont de
nature à éviter des troubles à l'ordre
public
et ils le font premier point
deuxièmement concernant les fiches s
un décret a été pris très précisément le
28 mai 2010 ce décret du 28 mai 2010
définit les conditions dans lesquelles
les informations contenues dans ces
fiches peuvent être communiquées et
détermine la liste des personnes
auxquelles ces formations peuvent être
communiquées et ce décret pris par le
précédent gouvernement interdit la
communication dans les conditions que
vous venez d'indiquer des informations
contenues par les fiches
est-ce donc ce que vous demandez est
totalement illégal cependant comme je
souhaite qu'il puisse être répondu
favorablement à la préoccupation qui est
la vôtre j'ai pris un certain nombre de
dispositions
j'ai réuni les grandes associations
d'élus le 6 septembre je pense que le
président de la rfl de vous en informer
pour dire que nous mettions en place un
groupe de travail 2 que le fichier que
le ffs ferté que j'ai mis en place et
qui comporte treize mille noms et qui
est déclinée localement permettra au
préfet de prendre contact avec
l'ensemble des élus pour leur donner les
informations dont ils ont besoin et j'ai
envoyé le 14 septembre
une circulaire aux préfets pour leur
demander de mettre en oeuvre ses
instructions
voilà qu il